yeah welcome to this video playing with
Vicki to our victory Lou from Spain okay
playto Mayer to a few Sicilians are just
myths clickable Sicilians okay d3 done
Kings Indian attack the official played
that quite a number of times against you
six with the very good results this is
one good reply a 65-yard not ideal
moving this twice but really see fine
okay but it sets up them the board
winning structure will see 585 under
should give black decent play yeah this
c4 would be one is some is very strange
I think like us already a significantly
better here I have this f5 idea while
white has no active play here
threatening f4 okay
okay so aged aged six and g5 let's do
that before I can what really giving me
g5g for some quite surprising okay let's
let's go at him not think too much and
spend time so g4 or 92 g6 yeah he's got
d 4 as a possible counterplay so yeah a
g6 is okay d 4 is not the end of the
world I can reply with g4 even with age
58 right though we can take this is not
good maybe he's got to e5
okay not what I intended to do but not
bad just take this play here intending
to play f3
very very instantly plate i thought this
helps me a great deal control g5 know
the Pawn a thread and ff3 looks terrible
yeah this is our glee f3
I have a brilliant idea daddykins just
always instantly some move not even
trying to defend this I mean I don't
understand that sorry and this is
already beyond repair probably but still
you can contrive k Bishop a tree
tweenage form
one of the good-looking moves
just feathering Bishop g2 Queen h1
check which was probably know something
you couldn't can't offend against anyway
this is made now quite resigned I just
don't understand why I to play all moves
instantly and very committal ones I mean
sorry I always get get flagged for
criticizing the opponents but what can
you do you simply cannot play a move
like this in two seconds it's super
committal and you need to consider it a
while I mean the first impression is
that it's just completely terrible and
if you want to play it and think and say
ok I know it looks terrible but it may
be at some point you cannot figure that
out in two seconds then this is just
just terrible for either already yeah
threatened g4 so probably needs to do
that and yeah here I didn't want to take
but always possibility just occupying
this this good square and now I'm
there's always this f3 idea oops so
stupid this f3 idea the only
well-positioned piece that white has is
the knight on d4 which she instantly
exchanged on c6 improving my pawn
structure and no it's it's completely
over how to ever defend that g4 take
stakes and now you have this dead piece
and you not even try to spend a couple
of seconds to figure out the defense
there probably isn't any but if you move
instantly you won't find it simply
alright thanks for watching